vor ungefähr sechs wochen haben sophie
und ich unsere hündin mai das sprechen
beigebracht
angefangen hat das ganze damals dass die
sprachtherapeutin christina hammer
angeblich erfolgreich eine methode der
unterstützten kommunikation auf deren
hund stelle angewandt hat bin ich was
los deswegen als ich meine streiche ich
herkomme aber viel mehr als das haben
wir eigentlich aufgedeckt wie man durch
geschickte kommandos als ich sagt thomas
dann drückte thomas pannen trickserei
hinter der kamera oder auch einfach
zufall die illusion eines sprechenden
bundes erzeugen kann und laster tik tok
trend aus den usa
vielleicht auch eher eine kombination
aus zufall und großzügiger
interpretation ist und da stellt sich
jetzt mir die frage wenn man mit relativ
leicht fällt barren content in den usa
millionen von klicks erzielen kann
klappt das dann auch einfach so eins zu
eins deutschland und wie reagieren die
leute glauben die das in den vergangenen
30 tagen wollen wir aktiv auf zick zack
und haben regelmäßig videos von unserer
hündin gepostet in denen sie
vermeintlich spricht ja wohin soll ich
schauen mal so sophie okay ich schaue
mal nach der sophie samt süßem
profilbild und niedlichen beschreibungen
und das ist da war passiert alles
beginnt mit einem profil das wir jetzt
erstellen werden als name haben wir uns
für meist instagram namen entschieden my
dog mai das profilbild wird auch von den
zyklen genommen perfekt in die
beschreibung schreiben wir ich kann
sprechen und ein paar süße images sowie
ein link zu einem youtube video mit der
überschrift so habe ich sprechen gelernt
damit sind wir transparent und jeder
zuschauer kann sich ein bild davon
machen wie die beiden wirklich spricht
das erste zeigt dass wir gepostet haben
habe ich einfach aus dem youtube video
geschnitten ich muss mich ja schon ein
wenig zurecht finden weil es mein erster
tik tok aller zeiten war doch dann war
auch schon raus in seiner freien
wildbahn
während der post sich jetzt seinen weg
in den feeds der user band kann ich mal
ein bisschen was davon berichten dass
beim eiskonsum
zwar nehme weil also ja wenn man sein
profil und seine likes und seine
kommentare abdecken willkommen beim
starten der app nicht an der startseite
der app vorbei und so kann es schon mal
passieren dass seine aufmerksamkeit ein
bisschen gequetscht wird und man fünf
minuten scrollt oder 50 es ist schon
echt schwierig den content auf tik tok
zu beschreiben aber ja das erste was mir
aufgefallen ist ist genau der trend der
plattform seinen teils schlechten ruf
verliehen hat auch extrem
materialistische und oberflächliche
inhalte prägen die landschaft der
plattform und der trend von videos wie
diesen in denen jemand natürlich
gestellt ja so cool ist dass
irgendwelche girls dafür ihren freund
betrügen und das findet dann jeder super
toll
ja dieser trend ist nur die spitze des
eisbergs aber viele sagen ja man muss
dem algorithmus zeit geben sich kennen
zu lernen also habe ich das gemacht und
nach 30 tagen wovon ich zugegeben nach
zwei wochen als konsument gar keine lust
hatte sie meine startseite so aus
wissenschaft ein bisschen fotografie
etwas finanzen eine prise sport und
mittlerweile könnte ich stunden so
weitermachen also mega gut oder dinge
die mich interessieren sport finanzen
reisen naja die ticker kultur zwingend
eine craig scheinbar meiner erfahrung
nach irgendwie auf unsichtbare art und
weise dazu hier ein content auf extrem
oberflächliche art und weise zu
erstellen
man schaut sich an zuerst spannendes
video an in der hoffnung auf auflösung
nur um dann mit einem link zu einer
webseite vertröstet zu werden jeder
versucht irgendwie auf krampf hip und
cool sein und ich kann es nicht genau
definieren aber selbst hoch qualitativer
content der mich eigentlich interessiert
ist auf tik tok meistens irgendwie eklig
und dann reden die auch immer so schnell
wenn man natürlich innerhalb von 60
sekunden überhaupt nichts rüber bringen
kann und jeder der wirklich irgendwie
was rüber bringen
dem ist klar dass das auf tik tok halt
einfach nicht das richtige format ist
mittlerweile sind 24 stunden vergangen
und unser video hat 170000 auf gruppe
und 20.000 likes was zum henker
das kann auch nicht so leicht sein oder
um bestimmt war das nur ein glücksgriff
aber um das herauszufinden wird direkt
der nächste post gekostet aber wie hat
das tik tok publikum auf unseren fake
reagiert wer ist auch von youtube ich
kenne ich glaube jetzt nichts mehr auf
twitter ist echt unglaublich wie einfach
das
wie hast du ihm das beigebracht könnt
ihr noch mehr videos machen
wie bringt man das bei möchte das mit
unserem auch probieren wie geil ist das
denn will sie hat bestimmt lange
gedauert das beizubringen oder die
meisten glauben dass also und auch der
anteil von denen die wissen wer oder was
hinter dem ganzen steckt wir den
zukünftigen post von mal zu mal abnehmen
unser zweites tik tok bekommt deutlich
weniger klicks und als ich abends ins
bett gehe ist er gerade mal bei 15.000
war also doch nur ein glücksgriff dieser
post läuft einfach besser als meine
youtube-videos und ist am ende des tages
über 700.000 aufrufen mittlerweile sind
es über 2,9 millionen innerhalb von
knapp einem monat auf einen billigen
recycelten clip den ich auf wenn zwei
tage halten account wird ein paar
followern hochgeladen habe
ironischerweise hat dieses video nach
einem monat so viele klicks wie man
meist geklickte das video nach zwei
jahren auf einem youtube kanal mit knapp
600.000 abonnenten der seit mehreren
jahren die jede freie sekunde meines
lebens in anspruch nimmt und mein
lebenswerk darstellt aber wie viele sind
eigentlich diesen tick tock nix wert im
vergleich zu youtube meine ursprüngliche
annahme war dass videos auf tik tok nur
so viele aufrufe haben bei leute am
großteil des contents nur vorbei vision
aber wenn man mal die interaktions rate
von youtube mit hier zum beispiel 2000
kommentaren und 100000 likes auf knapp
drei millionen views mit der von tik tok
vergleicht wird schnell klar dass das
nicht unbedingt stimmt denn dort sind es
ähnlich viele kommentare und 400.000
likes auf dieselbe klickzahlen in der
tat weniger wert sind tik tok views aber
tendenziell was das finanzielle an
nicht zuletzt da es selbst für die
meisten großen tik tok nutzer noch keine
richtige monetarisierung sind voll
struktur gibt wie man sie zum beispiel
von youtube kennt aber jetzt hat es uns
als john interessiert wenn direkt die
ersten zwei post solche hits sind und
innerhalb von zwei tagen 19.000 voller
mitgebracht haben
wie sich das dann nach einem monat aus
hochgerechnet auf 30 tage werden dass
nämlich 285.000 follower aber kommen so
leicht kann es doch nicht sein oder
oder bitte direkt der post am nächsten
tag wieder nicht taktiert erfolgreich
das 65 geht auch komplett sein
[Musik]
in den ersten sieben tagen haben sich
also durch daily post über 50.000
follower angesammelt clips zwischen
100.000 und buchstäblich über eine
million views und hier jetzt auch schon
die ganze auflösung des videos werden
den rest des monats nicht komplett daily
kos sind aber trotzdem man es am ende
knapp 80.000 follower und das alles halt
irgendwie nicht echt
die meisten leute die sich die videos
mittlerweile anschauen die glaube ich
habe nicht so den plan was da eigentlich
ab auch wenn es einige gibt die wissen
was abgeht aber sich die videos trotzdem
einmal gerne anschauen was hat einfach
lustig ist so einen hund zu sehen der
auf irgendwelche knöpfe drückt wenn ich
auch lustig als konsument selber ist
meine meinung wie gesagt wenn ich fix ob
nicht so gut aber weil einfach gefühlt
jeder im team also sebastian felix alle
absolut süchtig davon sind und weil sich
das vielleicht auch ein bisschen ändern
muss mit dem schlechten content findet
ihr jetzt auch tik tok nicht nur videos
von allein sondern auch welche von mir
zu den selbst experimenten und so weiter
und so fort mein abschließendes fazit
ist dass wenn man das jetzt mit der mai
komplett übertreiben würde und weiterhin
daily post würde dass sie ganz flott
über eine million follower hat das wäre
eigentlich glaube ich kein problem
und das finde ich ist schon echt ist
schon recht wild ist schon echt verrückt
aber ticker kann natürlich auch
schattenseiten nicht nur was das
unternehmen angeht sondern natürlich
auch was einige nutzer angehen und so
wird einiges an content einfach
gestohlen nicht nur so das format nach
gemacht die wir das jetzt hier gemacht
haben sondern wirklich eins zu eins
gestohlen und nicht nur das ist mir
widerfahren sondern sogar
identitätsdiebstahl auf meinem 2 kanal
gibt es jetzt ein video in dem ich die
tatsache so ein bisschen auf die spur
geht das findet ihr hier irgendwo
genauso wie den abonnieren -button bühne
treten könnt wenn ihr mich auf dieser
reise begleiten möchte
macht's gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]